the important part for us to recognize
is depression is different than
demoralisation we use the word depressed
all the time boy it's hot and I'm very
uncomfortable I'm depressed oh it's the
weekend and it's raining I'm so
depressed I didn't get the date with the
girl I wanted I'm so depressed or I when
I'm younger and I'm a teenager I didn't
make the team I'm depressed or I failed
the test I'm depressed all of those are
part of the human condition that when
bad things happen we feel bad we feel
crummy which is very different than
depression which is a true disorder that
that has a set of symptoms that lasts at
least two weeks and exists every day
most of the day and the important part
for us to remember is that classic
depression is different than atypical
depression so teenagers and that teenage
brain is more susceptible to depression
than children are and certainly more
than adults so we have about two million
teenagers in the United States who have
depression and we have about 35 million
adults so what it sounds like adults are
more likely well we have less teenagers
and therefore the statistical risk is
much higher when you're an adolescent to
get depressed and therefore the big
chemical that seems to be affected by
this is serotonin and if you have don't
have enough serotonin available in your
brain hanging around your brain and if
you're eating it too fast or
metabolizing the too quickly you are
more likely to be anxious more likely to
be sad and irritable more likely to be
rageful and the other chemical that's
involved is norepinephrine and those two
chemicals when they those
neurotransmitters when they're out of
balance you are more susceptible to
full-blown depression
so I think the baseline we have to know
about is what are the symptoms we're
going to be tackling and so basically
teenage depression is slightly different
than adult depression adult depression
you lose both the appetite for the
search or for the hunt as well as the
appetite for the feast so I'm not going
out and hunting at my age but if I like
4 o'clock cappuccino and biscotti I have
to get out of my office and walk down
the street and go to the Starbucks and
get it and think about it and while I'm
hunting for it I'm already enjoying it
and the feast is actually drinking the
cappuccino and having the biscotti if
you are a teenager you may stop wanting
that pizza that you wanted always in
school ends but if someone gives you the
pizza you still can enjoy it and it
still tastes good when you're an adult
and you get depression if someone brings
you the cappuccino and the biscotti it
feels like hot water and cardboard so
teenagers when they get depressed lose
the the hunt but they still can have the
feast but the areas are appetite sleep
sex sex drive concentration and mood and
teenagers who get depressed tend to be
more irritable than sad and the
medicines that seem to work best are
medicines that will affect serotonin and
so that the number one set of
medications are the SSRIs so Prozac was
the first one and there been variations
on that theme whether it's zoloft or
lexapro or celexa all all of them
developed to get into this market as
well as to try to get less side effects
the important part is is that the old
antidepressants the tricyclics tov r''l
elavil or cardiotoxic if you took too
many of them
you could actually die with prozac like
substances you have to have a very very
big bottle it has to fall off the shelf
and it has to hit you in the head in the
right way
for it to kill you so that we have
patients who when their impulsively
upset and take a handful of this stuff
they still don't die
that's one of the reasons why when this
medicine came out on the market you
found that lots and lots of people were
put on this medication by their
internist by their OBGYN by their family
practitioner because there was a sense
that it was so safe so these medicines
basically plug up the the drain so to
speak in your brain where serotonin
could drain out and keeps serotonin
around so it's a serotonin reuptake
inhibitor so if you ate pure serotonin
it would go through your kidneys and
your liver and it's out of your system
before getting to the brain when you
take prozac it takes several weeks to
work it eventually gets to the
blood-brain barrier and what you have is
it's stopping your serotonin that your
brain is producing from being eliminated
too quickly